hello everyone and welcome to a game i
promised you in the previous video it is
jordan from forest vs pragananda and
it's a game that features uh positions
that are unlike any you've ever seen uh
well it depends on what kind of
positions you usually look like but this
is a very very off off topic when it
comes to
a chess at this level but that only
means that you guys will enjoy it even
more so let's dive straight into it it
is also from round one of the oslo
esports cup uh currently being played
jordan has the white for
the white pieces and he opens with d4
we have knight to f6 by prague we have c
for e6 uh knight to c3 and again bishop
to b4 we have the nimzo indian defense
uh queen to c2 going for the classical
variation and prague castles here we
have e4 and striking in the center with
the d5 we have e5 and 94 going after the
knight here so bishop to d3 just
continuing development and now striking
in the center with c5 so this is all
very very standard stuff both players
know exactly what's happening here
knight f3 c captures and d for knight
captures and knight to d7 now going
after the e5 pawn so we defended bishop
to f4 and now queen to h for attacking
the bishop here and of course g3 now we
have to defend our bishop we attack the
queen while doing so queen to h5 and now
uh jordan just castles we have g5 by
prague challenging the bishop here and
now a nice c captures on the e5 so well
this all looks very fancy this is
actually been played many many times and
of course both of them know it
uh so bishop captures on c3 this is the
standard reply b captures on c3 and now
not the g captures on f4 because it's
only temporary uh for example if you
capture on f4 d captures an e6 and who's
really attacking here uh for example
knight captures an e5 we're gonna play
bishop captures on e4 and after knight
the g4 threatening checkmate we can just
play h3 or rather even better we can
play knight to f3 h3 would be terrible
so we guard the h2 pawn this way and now
after bishop captures an e6 now we play
something like queen to d2 go after the
pawn black opens up the white king's
position a little bit but it's not all
that impressive if anyone should be
better here it should be white uh so
instead after b captures on c3 we have e
captures on d5 and now
usually what people play here is either
bishop captures an e4 or they just move
this bishop because okay yeah maybe it
overstayed it's welcome let's put back
the e3 and that's it however here jordan
plays g4 and that is the move that is
really really impressive uh
what can you play here it really doesn't
look like something you would expect uh
why would you allow someone to open up
your king like this with check
however it's uh it's what you're in
place uh but interestingly uh prague
declines the pawn now capturing the pawn
is in fact the absolute best move
recommended by the engine but of course
even though prague knows this uh without
preparing it he knows that jordan knows
it much better and this is a rapid game
uh he will have to burn a lot of time uh
trying to out uh out maneuver him in
this main line of this idea so the idea
is after queen captures and g4 we're
gonna play bishop to g3 already white
has a threat f3 will win material here
so you're gonna have to waste the move
with the queen we're going to win our
pawn back captures uh and after d
captures an e4 you can choose between
queen captures and even a move like f4
and this is something that if you don't
know what you're doing maybe you don't
want to allow
white all of this for example g captures
an f4 rook captures on f4 uh it looks uh
a a bit too much uh as the the rook
is coming to f1 it's i mean it's
overwhelming so instead prague uh
recollects himself and he plays queen to
h3 now asking jordan what do you have uh
what do you have now i can always
capture on g4 but now
uh you have to play something so he
moves the bishop back bishop to g3
prague eliminates the bishop knight
captures on g4 and g3 f captures on g3
and now knight captures an e5 going
after that g4 pawn but now queen to d2
going after queen captures and g5 so h6
prague defends it and now knight to f5
and here
you have to be very careful even though
it seems like you can capture the g4
pawn not really if you capture with the
queen you just blunder your queen knight
captures on h6 it's game over and if you
play knight captures well then knight to
the e7 check and again it's very very
difficult to defend this with black with
the bishop slicing over there the rook
slicing over here the other rook coming
to e1 uh it's a very very tough position
to play uh so instead what uh prague did
is uh not even captured the knight here
for example if bishop captures knight
then bishop captures knight and now
again if you go for knight captures and
g4 there's queen e2 and how are you
defending this you have to play h5
but then your queen is stuck on h3 for
the rest of the game which is not unlike
what happened in the game so instead
after this knight to f5 move prague
plays knight captures on d3 he says all
right it's maybe better to get rid of
the bishop
and then now comes knight to e7 czech
first king to g7 and queen captures on
g3 we have bishop to e6 uh you could go
for bishop characters and g4 but prague
decides to solidify with bishop to e6
now okay you're regarding the d5 pawn if
knight captures you can always just
well for example if knight captures on
v5 bishop captures on d5 queen captures
and then queen captures in g4 you get
your queen back into the game so instead
we have queen to d for check and here
prague has to play king to h7 but his
position isn't all that great however
prague played f6 here and unlike the
previous game that we've shown where
magnus played f6 uh here it's not a good
idea so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the absolute best
idea to win the game for jordan while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
crazy idea because it's definitely not
an easy one to spot and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
actually the simple queen d3 i say
simple because it's the exact opposite
of simple it seems like okay you're just
gonna destroy black here but bishop to
f7 would happen you block the g6 square
now queen f5 you go after the f6 pawn
now we're going to play bishop to e8
while still keeping an eye on the f6 and
g6 squares and now you're going to play
rook 8 to e1 and what can black play
here and notice that uh this entire time
black will be playing without a queen so
here you're going to play rook to d8
with the idea of trying to get another
defender here and not knight captures on
d5 rook to d6 trying to guard that f6
pawn and now rook to e7 with check
you're gonna block with bishop to f7 and
now white can play pretty much anything
and it's completely winning you can
start grabbing here but okay if you
capture right away then you allow black
this very tricky uh hope at defending
with queen captures on f1 so you can you
don't even have to do you can play rook
to d7 and it's very very ugly the rook
cannot capture because you just
completely destroy black here so the
rook has to move then you can you know
even add salt to the wound by capturing
a pawn here and there's really nothing
black can play here so this would be a
fine way uh to end things with queen to
d3 however he played knight to f5 with
check and this is not uh the way to win
the game uh prague eliminates the knight
quickly rook captures on f5 notice that
the black queen still cannot enter the
game so prague is playing without a
queen
rook ate the e8 and now comes rook a to
f1 so even though the queen can't get
away from the h3 square you can threaten
checkmate prague plays rook to e2 goes
after the h2 pawn here now you have to
defend it we have rook five back to f2
and now rook to e5 defending the d5 pawn
so here prague is saying all right i'm
playing without a queen but can you win
the game uh without uh me actually using
the queen and it's not an as easy as you
might think uh without being able to
capture the f6 pawn how do you how do
you go about this position of course you
can always capture on a7 but then you
allow the black queen into the game so
uh it seems like uh very odd that one
player cannot use his queen uh while
your queen is you know available uh to
move uh but there's no way to put any
pressure on the black king even though
the black king is completely open but
one uh one wrong move and the queen goes
back into the game and you cannot use
your rooks uh to add uh
more more defense than the to the g4
pawn it would be very very tricky to do
so so here queen to a4 now comes rook to
f7
uh preventing any uh
any checks here because even from here
you would be guarding the g4 pawn uh but
now we have rook back a queen back to d1
and here it's actually jordan that
misses a great idea that prague uh can
can use if he wants to win the game so
feel free to pause the video for the
second time now win the game for prague
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting
that all this roaming with the queen
wasn't all that useful and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is rook to e4 this is the only move that
wins the game and now it seems that
there's no way for jordan to prevent
frago from prague from bringing his
queen back into the game and okay jordan
plays queen captures on the e5 now
probably just plays queen captures on g4
and now it is definitely black who's
attacking here uh we have rook to f5 now
comes queen to e2 uh rook uh five back
to f2 attacking the black queen queen to
e3 now just uh not allowing the rook to
move king g2 now comes rook to e5 uh uh
chasing away the white queen queen to b3
and now comes b6 so here uh the material
on the board uh as you can see prague is
up one pawn but that's not the only
problem jordan has so here we have c4
offering a queen trade uh hopefully uh
if prague trades maybe jordan can
connect his pawns but just queen to e4
cher king to g1 and now rook to c5 going
after the c4 pawn and now you can pretty
much see that things are not um all that
great uh especially once this rook comes
into the game uh so queen to b2 now
comes queen to c6 uh going after the
pawn this way queen to e2 and now rook
captures on c4 we have h4 now jordan has
to resort to an all-out attack if he's
to survive this game rook to c3 goes
after the g3 pawn king h2 defending now
queen here again goes after the g3 pawn
rook g2 defending and now queen to e5
centralizing the queen now you are up
two pawns so of course prague is very
comfortable uh trading queens now queen
to h5 and now rook to e3 now we're gonna
try uh and trade off uh uh material plus
also we are just bringing the rook uh to
the e file or this way as prague will do
it as you'll see we have rook f to f2
controlling the second rank not allowing
any unnecessary trades and now rook to
e4
we have h captures on g5 h captures now
comes queen to d1 but now rook to d4
attacking the queen queen to f1 now
comes rook f8 uh rook to e2 and now rook
to e4 prague is very very happy to trade
material here we have king the g1 not
rook the e8 threatening to just win on
the spot so rook captures queen captures
and rook to d2 now so if you manage to
get some sort of a perpetual of course
there is still a chance uh but prague
will not allow this uh queen e3 check we
have queen to f2 now comes king to g6
now if jordan wants to trade prague is
very happy to do so king g2 queen
captures an f2 uh with czech king
captures and rook to e4 and now it's
only a matter of skill but also it is
not all that difficult to win this king
to f3 we have f5 now comes uh rook to d6
with check and now king to h5 we have
rook to d5 going after the pawn g4 check
king to f2 and now king to g5 atta
defending the f5 pawn a3 but now rook to
a4 we have rook to d3 defending now
comes b5 rook to b3 and now of course a6
so unfortunately for jordan he's running
auto moves rook to d3 now comes rook to
c4 king to e2 and now rook the c2 with
check king d1 now comes rook to f2 and
he was in this position on move 62 that
jordan forest resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh whatever you do doesn't really matter
a rook f3 is coming now you either have
to trade or you will start losing even
more material and both of it is losing
of course the king and pawn end game is
very much winning for black because
you're up two pawns and after a move
like this and this uh white is in swan
you have to move your king
lose more material and then it's a very
easy win
uh so after rook f2 iorden resigned the
game on on move 62 and a very very nice
victory for prague with the black pieces
uh who wins this game uh if you think
about it without a queen so uh here
after this f6 move that completely
weakened the position it's this is not
an easy tactic to spot in a rapid chess
make no mistake uh because you can see
that the the bishop defends the position
so easily uh but you know unfortunately
for jordan that was not the case here
but uh i mean the queen was trapped on
h3 for the entire game uh and then
jordan you know was just uh
loitering
with the queen uh he completely missed
this idea that prague used to go after
the uh the g4 pawn and that was enough
to bring the queen back into the game
but just incredible
that it's even possible to survive this
with your queen absolutely stuck here
this is just crazy
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it as a lot of you have
requested it as soon as it happened uh i
would like to thank pratam shekhar
mahajan us fdfri usfdfri nicolas padal
and andrew dabrovsky for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
oslo esports event that is currently
happening so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and tomorrow there is a very
special surprise
with a very special video so see you
soon